Greece's third major day of protests in
the two weeks since the accident people
here reject the argument that a station
master who put the Train on the wrong
track was the soul culprit they want
politicians to admit their
responsibility as well it's not an
accident it's a crime I feel for the
families that lost their children I
think the authorities are trying to
trick us the problem is the lack of
measures taken by governments and the
money that was set aside for safety some
people embezzled it
a human error can be corrected Safety
Systems exist to do that but all
governments seem to have stripped the
railway Network we students believe
transports run on a cost benefit
analysis the government accepts that
there are responsibilities beyond the
station Master
it is very likely that there was human
error but this doesn't detract from the
fact that if we had a nationwide system
of automated remote viewing it's certain
that this accident would never have
happened the government vows to have
automated Safety Systems in place by the
end of the summer and point out that
previous administrations also failed to
install safety features but it is this
government that is paying the political
price the protest March came to the
Hellenic Railways organization offices
and petered out but the political
problem remains new opinion polls out on
Sunday show that the government has shed
between three and four and a half
percentage points from its approval
ratings so it is unlikely to be able to
form a single-party government after
elections between now and July about 86
percent of respondents have said that
the railway accident is the number one
problem facing Greece today the ruling
new democracy conservatives are trying
to limit the political Fallout they'll
pay families of those killed a lifetime
pension of sixteen hundred dollars a
month and settle their outstanding taxes
and private debts but people here say
EXT changing human life for money is
precisely what led to the disaster when
Greek rail was privatized six years ago
and Staffing was cut John saropoulos Al
Jazeera Athens